What are the elements of a good life? What constitutes a happy life? These are age-old philosophical questions, but more than 80 years ago, researchers in Boston began working on a new way to answer them. During the closing years of the Depression and the beginning of World War II, these researchers began following two groups of people,
美好生活的要素是什么？什么构成了幸福的生活？这些都是古老的哲学问题，但在80多年前，波士顿的研究人员开始致力于寻找回答这些问题的新方法。在大萧条的最后几年和第二次世界大战初期，这些研究人员开始追踪两组人群，
several hundred Harvard undergraduates and several hundred boys from some of Boston's poorest neighborhoods. The researchers documented the participants' lives in exhausting detail through surveys, interviews with them and their families, medical records, and more. They then stuck with them, continuing to follow their lives as the men aged, all in an effort to find out which factors would ultimately lead to health, happiness, and well-being. Remarkably, 80 years later, the project is still going strong. It's called the Harvard Study of Adult Development, and it now includes many of the original
几百名哈佛大学本科生和几百名来自波士顿最贫困社区的男孩。研究人员通过调查、对他们及其家人的访谈、医疗记录等，详尽地记录了参与者的生活。随后，他们坚持追踪这些人的生活，随着他们的衰老持续进行，所有这些努力都是为了找出哪些因素最终会带来健康、幸福和福祉。值得注意的是，80年后，这项研究依然在蓬勃发展。它被称为“哈佛成人发展研究”，现在还包括了许多最初
participants' spouses and their children, too. So what have researchers learned from following these men and their families? What led to lasting happiness? Was it love, friendship, money, career success, all of the above? Is happiness innate? Are some people born happier than others and just destined to stay that way? Or is happiness something you can choose or cultivate? And how can examining the lives of people born more than a century ago yield insights that remain relevant for people today, living in a very different way? world. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Mark Schultz, the Associate Director of the Harvard Study of Adult Development. Dr. Schultz is also a
参与者的配偶和他们的子女。那么，研究人员从追踪这些人及其家庭中了解到了什么？是什么带来了持久的幸福？是爱、友谊、金钱、事业成功，还是以上皆是？幸福是天生的吗？有些人是否生来就比别人更快乐，注定要保持这种状态？还是说幸福是可以选择或培养的？通过审视一个多世纪前出生的人的生活，如何能得出对今天以完全不同的方式生活的人们仍然具有现实意义的见解？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是哈佛成人发展研究副主任马克·舒尔茨博士。舒尔茨博士同时也是
professor of psychology and director of the Data Science program at Brinmore College. Together with Study Director Dr. Robert Waldinger, he is co-author of The Good Life, Lessons from the World's largest scientific study of happiness, a new book based on the findings of the eight-decade study. Dr. Schultz, thank you for joining me today. I was such a pleasure to be with you, Kim. Let's start by having you tell us a little bit more about the history of this study. It started before you were born, and you and Dr. Waldinger are both, you are the fourth generation of researchers to lead it.
布林莫尔学院的心理学教授和数据科学项目主任。他与研究主任罗伯特·沃尔丁格博士合著了《美好生活：全球最大规模幸福科学研究的启示》一书，这是一本基于这项长达八十年研究成果的新书。舒尔茨博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。能和您在一起真是太高兴了，金。让我们从请您多讲讲这项研究的历史开始吧。它在您出生前就开始了，您和沃尔丁格博士都是第四代领导这项研究的研究人员。
How did it begin? How has it evolved over the years? Yeah, so it started in 1930s, as you suggested. And what made these studies unique, they initially began as two separate studies. So 724 participants, almost two-thirds were these inner-city boys and the remaining one-third were the Harvard students. Both studies were united in an interest in trying to identify what factors led to human thriving. So very unusual for the 1930s.
它是如何开始的？这些年来它是如何演变的？是的，正如您所说，它始于20世纪30年代。这些研究的独特之处在于，它们最初是作为两项独立的研究开始的。共有724名参与者，近三分之二是这些内城男孩，其余三分之一是哈佛学生。两项研究都致力于确定哪些因素导致了人类的蓬勃发展。这在20世纪30年代是非常罕见的。
This is an early form of positive psychology, if you will, curious about things in their life, factors that they brought to the table and their personality or their background that would lead to flourishing and growth for the rest of their lives. It certainly didn't begin as a study that would last 85 years, we're in our 85th year, but they were really interested in trying to identify human flourishing and the factors that shaped that. So made it fairly unique. It was also a study that was really interested in the lived experience of participants.
如果您愿意的话，这是积极心理学的早期形式，对他们生活中的事物、他们带入其中的因素、他们的个性和背景感到好奇，这些因素将导致他们余生的繁荣和成长。它当然不是作为一项会持续85年的研究开始的，我们现在正处于第85个年头，但他们确实有兴趣找出人类的繁荣以及塑造这种繁荣的因素。这使得它相当独特。这也是一项真正关注参与者生活体验的研究。
So the study began with home visits, interviews with parents. It always had interviews about every 10 years during the course of their life. lives, questionnaires, many, many questions, but also open-ended questions in which they could write responses. So the study developed very close connections to the participants across these 85 years. And the study has managed to hang on to 84% of its original participants and many of their children as well. Yeah.
因此，这项研究始于家访、与父母的访谈。在他们的一生中，大约每10年都会进行一次访谈、问卷调查，有很多很多问题，也有开放式的问题，他们可以在其中写下回答。因此，在这85年里，这项研究与参与者建立了非常密切的联系。这项研究成功地保留了84%的原始参与者，以及他们的许多子女。是的。
We all know that retaining participants can be a big challenge for researchers, especially for something as time-consuming as this study has been. What do you think has kept people from dropping out of the study? It's really remarkable, the participation rate, and I can't take credit for this. This is something that started in the very beginning in the 1930s. And I think there were probably a few factors. The study was really interested in people's experience. And I think most of us, including the participants that began, the study in the 30s,
我们都知道，留住参与者对研究人员来说可能是一个巨大的挑战，尤其是对于像这项研究这样耗时的项目。您认为是什么让人们没有退出这项研究？参与率确实非常了不起，我不能把功劳归于自己。这是从20世纪30年代一开始就有的东西。我认为可能有几个因素。这项研究真正关注的是人们的体验。我认为我们大多数人，包括30年代开始参与这项研究的参与者，
appreciate when people have a genuine interest in our experience, and they felt heard and noticed and seen. We like to talk about the fact that the Harvard students, it didn't surprise them that people would be interested in their experiences and they thought probably other people could learn from their experiences. Whereas the larger part of the sample of two-thirds that were growing up in inner city Boston, many of those families questioned why anyone would be interested in their son's experience. And they had to be persuaded that it was of value, that we were really interested in the circumstances they were growing up in to try and understand what led some kids to, to do well, to adapt well to the circumstances and perhaps flourish and other kids to struggle. So the relationship with participants over time really important. There was regular contact with participants. Over time, I think the participants began to look at the study as almost a part of their family. It was a place they could check in,
当人们对我们的经历表现出真正的兴趣时，我们会很感激，他们感到被倾听、被关注和被看见。我们喜欢谈论这样一个事实：哈佛学生并不惊讶人们会对他们的经历感兴趣，他们认为其他人可能会从他们的经历中学习。而占样本三分之二的、在波士顿内城长大的那部分人，许多家庭质疑为什么有人会对他们儿子的经历感兴趣。他们必须被说服，这是有价值的，我们确实对他们成长的环境感兴趣，试图了解是什么导致一些孩子做得很好，很好地适应了环境，也许蓬勃发展，而另一些孩子却在挣扎。因此，随着时间的推移，与参与者的关系非常重要。与参与者有定期的联系。随着时间的推移，我认为参与者开始把这项研究看作是他们家庭的一部分。这是一个他们可以签到的地方，
update us about how they were doing. The questions that we asked enabled them to reflect on their experiences. And maybe this was particularly important for a cohort of boys that were were born in the 20s and 30s, or even before that, that didn't get much of an opportunity to talk about their inner life and their inner experience. But really remarkable, that 84% participation rate across time is something the study's very proud of and I think deserves to be. There have been a number of people who have directed this study over the years. Who have been the other directors?
向我们更新他们的近况。我们提出的问题使他们能够反思自己的经历。也许这对于出生在20世纪20年代和30年代，甚至更早的一代男孩来说尤为重要，他们没有太多机会谈论自己的内心生活和内心体验。但确实非常了不起，84%的长期参与率是这项研究非常自豪的事情，我认为也理应如此。多年来，有许多人指导过这项研究。其他主任都是谁？
I mean, how did they continue? And how did you end up with this job? Yeah, so the study began, again, I suggest there's two separate studies. The Harvard student study began at the Harvard Health Center with an interest in trying to understand, again, what led to their students thriving and successful outcomes among their students. It was part of the Harvard Health Service, which made it particularly interesting because, again, they were interested in the sort of positive adaptive side of psychology, which was unusual for that time. Arlie Bach was one of the original organizers of the study, along with others, that helped shape the study. And then the other study was actually designed by two married couple, Gluck and Gluck, who had an interest in trying to understand delinquency and trying to understand how kids may pursue a path that, you know,
我的意思是，他们是如何继续下去的？您又是怎么得到这份工作的？是的，正如我所建议的，这项研究始于两项独立的研究。哈佛学生研究始于哈佛健康中心，旨在了解是什么导致了学生们的蓬勃发展和成功。它是哈佛健康服务的一部分，这使得它特别有趣，因为他们对心理学中积极适应的一面感兴趣，这在当时是不寻常的。阿利·巴赫是这项研究的最初组织者之一，与其他帮助塑造这项研究的人一起。而另一项研究实际上是由一对已婚夫妇格鲁克夫妇设计的，他们有兴趣了解犯罪行为，并试图了解孩子们如何走上一条，你知道，
put them in touch with the law, challenged the circumstances that they were living in and the kind of ability to adapt. These studies were united by the third director, who was George Valiant, who led the study for many years and was very important. keeping it alive. About 20 years ago, Bob Waldinger, who I co-wrote this book, The Good Life with, was asked by George to begin to take over the study. And Bob and I already had a working relationship going on at that point, about 10 years. And Bob brought me along. So I wrote on his coattails to become part of this study. So you mentioned that initially in the early phases, there was some interest in looking at delinquency? Was there sort of a preconceived notion that these underprivileged boys were going to be more likely to be delinquent and the Harvard boys would of course be golden.
让他们与法律接触，挑战他们所处的生活环境和适应能力。这些研究由第三任主任乔治·瓦利安特统一起来，他领导这项研究多年，对于保持其活力非常重要。大约20年前，我和他合著《美好生活》的鲍勃·沃尔丁格被乔治要求开始接管这项研究。当时鲍勃和我已经有大约10年的工作关系了。鲍勃带上了我。所以我搭了他的顺风车，成为了这项研究的一部分。那么您提到最初在早期阶段，人们对研究犯罪行为有一些兴趣？是否有一种先入为主的观念，认为这些贫困男孩更有可能犯罪，而哈佛男孩当然会是金子？
Absolutely. I think that was part of again. It was two separate groups. So it wasn't one group that was saying the Harvard students were going to be the ones who would be successful and would be happy in life and the inner city kids would follow a different path. But the participants that are part of our study, the Harvard study of adult development, were only one part of the study of delinquency. That study began with already identified delinquents that were. already experiencing challenges in life and difficulty with the law and were part of official records in Boston. And the group that we followed was the comparison group of kids that were doing okay despite the circumstances they were growing up in, but we're growing up in very challenging poor circumstances. Most of them lived in tenement buildings without running water. They were born to immigrant families, most of them, I think almost 70% of them.
绝对是。我认为这又是其中的一部分。这是两个独立的群体。所以并不是一个群体说哈佛学生会是成功和幸福的人，而内城孩子会走不同的道路。但作为我们研究一部分的参与者，哈佛成人发展研究只是犯罪研究的一部分。那项研究始于已经确定的犯罪者，他们已经在生活中经历挑战，与法律有困难，并且是波士顿官方记录的一部分。而我们追踪的群体是那些尽管在成长环境中面临挑战，但表现良好的孩子的对照组，但他们是在非常具有挑战性的贫困环境中长大的。他们大多数人住在没有自来水的公寓楼里。他们出生在移民家庭，大多数人，我想几乎70%的人。
So this was a sample of saying a lot. of challenges in life. But they were the comparison group. So people were trying to understand how they were doing okay despite the challenges that they were facing in these very poor neighborhoods. One of the challenges around doing any kind of research is funding. And here is a study that's in its 85th year. How have you managed to keep it going? Where are the dollars coming from? So over the years, we've been really fortunate. And part of it is certainly serendipity and luck. And I want to kind of highlight that. There's perseverance and luck. has been a big part of it. People never imagine the study would last this long. When the study
所以这是一个有很多生活挑战的样本。但他们是对照组。所以人们试图了解他们尽管在这些非常贫困的社区面临挑战，却表现得很好。进行任何研究的挑战之一是资金。而这是一项已经进入第85个年头的研究。你们是如何设法让它继续下去的？钱从哪里来？所以多年来，我们非常幸运。其中一部分当然是机缘巧合和运气。我想强调这一点。毅力和运气是其中的很大一部分。人们从未想象过这项研究会持续这么久。当研究
began, it had critical funding from the grant, what became the grant foundation. So this was WT Grant who had started some department stores and was really interested in early development, continues the grant foundations continues to be interested in that work. And the study received funding at critical points along the way from the grant foundation. We've had a lot of federal grants to study specific questions that have allowed us to expand the reach and also the focus of the study. And more recently, because the study has developed a kind of public recognition, it's allowed us to raise some private monies as well to continue the research. But money is always a critical challenge. And I think, you know, a testament to the three generations
开始时，它获得了来自基金会的关键资金，即后来的格兰特基金会。这是WT格兰特，他开了一些百货公司，对早期发展非常感兴趣，格兰特基金会继续对这项工作感兴趣。这项研究在沿途的关键点从格兰特基金会获得了资金。我们获得了许多联邦拨款来研究具体问题，这使我们能够扩大研究的范围和重点。最近，由于这项研究获得了某种公众认可，它也使我们能够筹集一些私人资金来继续这项研究。但资金始终是一个关键的挑战。我认为，你知道，这是对鲍勃和我之前的几代人的证明，
that came before Bob and I sort of clever strategic leadership to continue the study. I think there's a having now been involved in the study for 20 years there's probably an experience that other past leaders have had there's a kind of tremendous um devotion to the study from participants they're giving generously of their life they're they're revealing intimate details of their experience all in the service of trying to help others or to help move science further and i think that really motivates you as a leader it certainly motivates me to try and do right by those participants uh to answer questions that are meaningful, both to scientists and to the general public as well. So I think, you know, over time, it becomes a kind of bigger enterprise and maybe even more
某种聪明的战略领导力来继续这项研究。我认为，现在参与这项研究20年了，可能有一种过去领导者有过的经历，参与者对这项研究有一种巨大的奉献精神，他们慷慨地贡献自己的生活，他们揭示了他们经历的亲密细节，所有这些都是为了帮助他人或帮助推动科学进一步发展，我认为这确实激励了你作为一名领导者。它当然激励我努力为这些参与者做正确的事，回答对科学家和公众都有意义的问题。所以我认为，随着时间的推移，它变成了一种更大的事业，也许甚至更多
investment in trying to keep it alive and going. But it's always a challenge to keep a study like this going. Is a lot of the data publicly available or say shared with other researchers? So certainly data has been shared with other researchers. We are engaged in lots of collaborations with others, and increasingly we're trying to archive data that's been de-identified in public resources, and that's actually ongoing that effort. One of the challenges in a study like this, and it's a really interesting challenge, it's a privacy issue. When you have so much data going across so many years, the privacy issues are pretty significant.
投入到试图保持它的活力和持续性。但保持这样一项研究的持续性始终是一个挑战。大部分数据是公开的吗，或者说是与其他研究人员共享的吗？当然，数据已经与其他研究人员共享。我们正在与他人进行许多合作，并且我们越来越多地尝试将已去标识的数据存档在公共资源中，这项工作实际上正在进行中。像这样的一项研究的挑战之一，这是一个非常有趣的挑战，是隐私问题。当你拥有跨越这么多年的这么多数据时，隐私问题是非常重大的。
And as computers get better and better at piecing together little bits of information to figure out the bigger puzzles, we have to be even more careful. So what we've done is to try and think about the de-identified data that doesn't put anyone at risk of being identified in the study. And that can be archived in places where people can gain permission to work with those data. And then there's other data that's too sensitive that it needs to be kept behind a kind of wall. And perhaps collaborators can engage with us about whether they're equipped to handle that kind of information. And of course, promise to keep it confidential as we have over 85 years. Now, the original participants in the study were all white men from the Boston area, and researchers
随着计算机在拼凑零碎信息以解决更大难题方面变得越来越好，我们必须更加小心。所以我们所做的是尝试考虑不会使任何人面临被识别风险的去标识数据。这可以存档在人们可以获得许可使用这些数据的地方。然后还有其他太敏感的数据，需要保存在某种墙后。也许合作者可以与我们接触，看看他们是否有能力处理那种信息。当然，承诺像我们85年来所做的那样保持机密。现在，这项研究的最初参与者都是波士顿地区的白人男性，研究人员
today would, of course, aim for a more diverse group. How do you address that issue and make sure that the findings you're getting from this study remain relevant beyond the relatively homogenous group of participants? This is just such an important question. I would just also add anyone who does longitudinal research. This was a group that was born in the early 1900s, so things have changed, so the relevance of their experience also. We need to raise questions and be critical about that.
今天当然会瞄准一个更多样化的群体。您如何解决这个问题，并确保您从这项研究中获得的发现对于相对同质的参与者群体之外的人仍然具有相关性？这是一个非常重要的问题。我也想补充任何做纵向研究的人。这是一个出生在20世纪初的群体，所以情况已经改变了，所以他们经历的相关性也改变了。我们需要提出问题并对此持批评态度。
So very hard to collect 85 years of data. If we could begin again, we would have had a more diverse sample in some ways. Certainly would have included women in that sample at the beginning as opposed to including them along the way. We are studying now the 1,300, more than 1,300 children of the original participants. So the study has gotten slightly more diverse. But no one study really that studies people this closely can capture the diversity of experience that we all represent in the world. So it's really critical to go beyond any one study. And this is just good science. This is the idea about replication of findings. So in our book, we don't just rely on
所以收集85年的数据非常困难。如果我们能重新开始，我们在某些方面会有一个更多样化的样本。当然，一开始就会把女性包括在样本中，而不是在过程中把她们包括进来。我们现在正在研究最初参与者的1300多名子女。所以这项研究已经变得稍微多样化了一些。但没有哪一项研究能如此密切地研究人们，能捕捉到我们在世界上所代表的所有经验的多样性。所以超越任何一项研究是非常关键的。这就是好的科学。这就是关于发现复制的想法。所以在我们的书中，我们不仅仅依赖于
the findings from the Harvard study. We rely on hundreds of studies that have asked similar kinds of questions, perhaps with different methods, perhaps at different times in different countries. So we're looking for that signal that repeats across many studies that suggests something is important to well-being. And that's something that we found is that it's that it's its good relationships are critical for our happiness and for our physical health as well. And that data, those findings don't just come from our own research because it's important, Kim, as you're suggesting, to be able to generalize to broader populations. It comes from hundreds and hundreds of studies that have happened all across the world
哈佛研究的发现。我们依赖于数百项提出了类似问题的研究，也许方法不同，也许在不同的时间、不同的国家。所以我们正在寻找在许多研究中重复出现的信号，这表明某件事对福祉很重要。这是我们发现的一件事，那就是良好的人际关系对我们的幸福和身体健康至关重要。这些数据、这些发现不仅仅来自我们自己的研究，因为正如您所建议的那样，金，能够推广到更广泛的人群是很重要的。它来自世界各地发生的成百上千项研究
and across decades of time, right? The really critical question of circumstances change so much in today's society that, you know, data that were collected 100 years ago or 50 years ago, not have relevance. That's a really important question to ask. Well, let's talk about the book and its main focus, which I think is, as you've said, the importance of relationships in our lives. And you illustrate that in a lot of different ways in the book, one of which is by contrasting to men whom you call John Marsden and Leo DeMarco. Can you talk about them who they are, were and the different characteristics? Yeah, so John Marston and Leo DeMarco were two of the students
并且跨越了几十年，对吧？真正关键的问题是，当今社会的情况发生了如此大的变化，以至于100年前或50年前收集的数据可能没有相关性。这是一个非常重要的问题。好吧，让我们谈谈这本书及其主要焦点，我认为正如您所说，是人际关系在我们生活中的重要性。您在书中以许多不同的方式说明了这一点，其中之一是通过对比您称之为约翰·马斯登和里奥·德马科的两个人。您能谈谈他们是谁，以及他们的不同特征吗？是的，所以约翰·马斯登和里奥·德马科是两名学生
who began the study as participants from the Harvard sample. They were both very good students. John Marsden was interested in becoming a lawyer. He went on to have a very successful career in law. This was after World War II intervened in both their lives. So both John and Leo were interested in serving in the military. John, it turned out, had some medical concerns and wasn't able to serve, but he served stateside in support of the military efforts in World War II.
他们作为哈佛样本的参与者开始了这项研究。他们都是非常优秀的学生。约翰·马斯登对成为一名律师很感兴趣。他后来在法律领域拥有非常成功的职业生涯。这是在第二次世界大战干预了他们两人的生活之后。所以约翰和里奥都有兴趣在军队服役。事实证明，约翰有一些医疗问题，无法服役，但他二战期间在国内支持军事工作。
went to a leading law school, started to work in a leading firm, so very successful by conventional standards in his career. He taught law for law students as well, did some public service work, so it was quite a varied and successful career. But he struggled in his relationships, that he had a marriage that was not satisfying, and marriage ended, he had another relationship that was also not satisfying with him, with the connections that he had within his family, there were lots of conflict and disappointment, and it was something where he often felt alone and not supported by others. So he lived a life that by the standards of the whole sample was on the very lowest end of happiness. He was unhappy for most of his life. Leo, who graduated
进入了一所顶尖法学院，开始在一家顶尖律所工作，所以按传统标准衡量，他的职业生涯非常成功。他还为法律系学生教授法律，做了一些公共服务工作，所以这是一个相当多样化和成功的职业生涯。但他的人际关系很挣扎，他的婚姻并不令人满意，婚姻结束了，他还有另一段关系对他来说也不令人满意，与他家庭中的联系，有很多冲突和失望，他经常感到孤独，没有得到他人的支持。所以他过着一种按整个样本标准衡量，处于幸福感最低端的生活。他一生中大部分时间都不快乐。里奥，他毕业于
about the same time, studied history, was interested in being a writer, served abroad in the Pacific region in World War II, kept very detailed notes that he thought he might turn into a book or a series of articles after the war. When the war ended, he had to go home because his mom got sick with a pretty serious illness. And he ended up not being able to pursue his dream of being a writer and instead became a high school teacher. And he was a very successful high school teacher, well loved, very connected to the community that he taught in. So respected by peers, students would talk about him. And he lived a life embedded in connections to others, very close to his family.
大约在同一时间，学习历史，对成为一名作家很感兴趣，二战期间在太平洋地区服役，做了非常详细的笔记，他认为战后可能会把这些笔记变成一本书或一系列文章。战争结束时，他不得不回家，因为他的母亲患上了一种相当严重的疾病。他最终没能追求成为作家的梦想，而是成为了一名高中老师。他是一位非常成功的高中老师，深受爱戴，与他任教的社区联系非常紧密。所以受到同龄人的尊重，学生们会谈论他。他过着一种嵌入与他人联系的生活，与家人非常亲近。
He met his wife soon after he returned from the war. She was the love of his life, remained married to her for his entire life, very close to his daughters and to his grandchildren. And he turned out to be one of the happiest people in the study. So we used John and Leo to illustrate this idea that it's not really the circumstances of your life or the success that you have at work that dictates your happiness. It really the data suggests, not just these two stories, the data suggests it's your, connections with others, the quality of those connections with others. What about the role of money in life? A lot of people think that making a lot of money is going to make them happy.
他从战争回来后不久就遇到了他的妻子。她是他的挚爱，与她结婚了一辈子，与他的女儿和孙子们非常亲近。他最终成为了研究中最快乐的人之一。所以我们用约翰和里奥来说明这个观点，即并不是你生活的环境或你在工作中取得的成功决定了你的幸福。数据表明，不仅仅是这两个故事，数据表明是你的，与他人的联系，与他人联系的质量。那么金钱在生活中的作用呢？很多人认为赚很多钱会让他们快乐。
What did you find in this research? Were people in this study who ended up wealthier and with more career success, were they any happier or healthier on an average basis? They weren't, and that's consistent largely with other research that's out there. Although the research on the relationship between money and happiness is complicated, and it's complicated for a reason that I think will make sense to most listeners. The most cited study is a study that suggests that there is a small connection between money and happiness until you get to about $75,000, which at that time was the average salary for a middle class family in the United States. And after that, that relationship begins to disappear. Other studies have found it might continue, but it's very, very small.
你们在这项研究中发现了什么？研究中那些最终更富有、事业更成功的人，平均而言是否更快乐或更健康？他们并没有，这在很大程度上与其他现有的研究是一致的。尽管关于金钱与幸福之间关系的研究很复杂，而且我认为对大多数听众来说，这种复杂是有道理的。引用最多的一项研究表明，在达到大约75,000美元之前，金钱与幸福之间存在微弱的联系，当时这是美国中产阶级家庭的平均工资。在那之后，这种关系开始消失。其他研究发现它可能会持续，但非常非常小。
I would say tiny is probably the best characterization of that. So what we think is going on, and this I think is a belief that many others have is that money, at least in the United States, and probably true in other Western or industrialized societies, gives you a certain kind of control over life. And it provides the kinds of things that we think are important for basic needs. So it provides us with security, access to food. In the United States, importantly, access to health care. So sort of safety, food security, some control over our life.
我会说微小可能是对它的最好描述。所以我们认为正在发生的事情，我认为这也是许多人的信念，即金钱，至少在美国，可能在其他西方或工业化社会也是如此，给了你某种对生活的控制。它提供了我们认为对基本需求很重要的东西。所以它为我们提供了安全感、获得食物的途径。在美国，重要的是，获得医疗保健的途径。所以某种安全、粮食安全、对我们生活的一些控制。
And after that, it doesn't seem to add very much to our happiness. So we had people who were at the very high end, and I mean really high end of the income spectrum, who were very unhappy. And people at the low end, particularly folks that have grown up in these poor Boston neighborhoods that lived a very simple but productive life. They might have worked in factories for much of their life. They were quite happy and fulfilled. with the nature of their life, the circumstances of their life.
在那之后，它似乎并没有给我们的幸福增加太多。所以我们有一些处于收入谱系最高端，我的意思是真正高端的人，他们非常不快乐。而处于低端的人，特别是那些在波士顿贫困社区长大，过着非常简单但富有成效的生活的人。他们可能一生大部分时间都在工厂工作。他们相当快乐和满足。对他们生活的本质，他们生活的环境。
Now, there's some research that suggests that people have happiness set points, that some people are naturally happier than others, and that we tend to return to our set point despite life's ups and downs. What did you find in your research? Do happy people stay happy? Do unhappy people stay unhappy? Or does it change through life? So the answer to these questions are always, it's complicated, right?
现在，有一些研究表明人们有幸福设定点，有些人天生比别人更快乐，尽管生活有起有落，我们倾向于回到我们的设定点。你们在研究中发现了什么？快乐的人会一直快乐吗？不快乐的人会一直不快乐吗？还是它会随着生活而改变？所以这些问题的答案总是，很复杂，对吧？
So I want to say yes to each of your questions. So there's no question that there's some. some genetic influence on our happiness. Happiness is often measured in two ways. When we talk about all the research that's going on about happiness, it's measured by looking at your momentary feelings that you have across the day. Do you experience a lot of joy and happiness? If we asked you questions about your mood, you report that.
所以我想对您的每个问题都说“是”。所以毫无疑问，有一些。基因对我们的幸福有影响。幸福通常以两种方式衡量。当我们谈论所有关于幸福的研究时，它是通过观察你一天中感受到的瞬间感受来衡量的。你体验到很多快乐和幸福吗？如果我们问你关于你情绪的问题，你会报告这一点。
And then there's also the more longstanding component about your overall satisfaction with life, the meaning that you find in life, your sense of purpose. So those two components probably have a genetic component. Some research that's well-sighted suggests that maybe genes affect about 50% of our happiness. And it's always fun when it's about 50% because we have the glass half empty and half full at the same time. So that means that genes are important, but it also means that the circumstances we live in and our daily decisions, the activities that we do, the way we live our life, are very important for our happiness. And we certainly find that in our study.
然后还有关于你对生活总体满意度、你在生活中找到的意义、你的目标感的更长期的组成部分。所以这两个组成部分可能都有遗传成分。一些被广泛引用的研究表明，基因可能影响我们大约50%的幸福感。当它是大约50%时总是很有趣，因为我们同时拥有半空和半满的杯子。所以这意味着基因很重要，但也意味着我们生活的环境和我们的日常决定、我们进行的活动、我们生活的方式，对我们的幸福非常重要。我们当然在我们的研究中发现了这一点。
We also find two kinds of changes. One kind of change is a kind of normative change across time. So, for example, if we look at marital satisfaction, we find something that looks like a U-shaped curve, that couples begin their marriage, relatively happy during the time when they're raising children right after they have a child, so the time that the child leaves the proverbial nest. Marital satisfaction declines. I've done other research that confirms that with the transition to parenthood. And then it begins to pick up again for most people. So this is on average, marital satisfaction picks up. And this is similar to other looks, other curves of satisfaction.
我们还发现了两种变化。一种变化是随着时间的推移，某种规范性的变化。例如，如果我们观察婚姻满意度，我们会发现某种看起来像U型曲线的东西，夫妻在婚姻开始时，在抚养孩子期间相对快乐，就在他们有了孩子之后，所以孩子离开所谓的巢穴的时间。婚姻满意度下降。我做过其他研究，证实了向为人父母的转变。然后它开始再次回升，对大多数人来说。所以这是平均而言，婚姻满意度回升。这类似于其他外观，其他满意度曲线。
So if you look at happiness curves, we see a modest U curve with happiness dipping in middle age and then picking up again as people grow old. So those are really interested, those normative changes or changes on average. But we also find in this very close study of 724 individuals and the other children is that people have their own changes and trajectories are time, that people have events that have happened to them, some expected, some unexpected, and often change their trajectory of their happiness as well. So it might be the loss of a job and the finding of some very new kind of meaning. It might be getting out of a relationship or getting into a new one, that people have their own individual curves by which I want to say more simply and plainly.
所以如果你看幸福曲线，我们会看到一个温和的U型曲线，幸福感在中年下降，然后随着人们变老再次回升。所以那些非常有趣，那些规范性的变化或平均变化。但我们在这个对724个人和其他子女的非常密切的研究中也发现，人们随着时间有自己的变化和轨迹，人们有发生在他们身上的事件，有些是预期的，有些是意外的，也经常改变他们幸福的轨迹。所以这可能是失业和找到某种非常新的意义。这可能是走出一段关系或进入一段新的关系，人们有他们自己的个人曲线，我想更简单明了地说。
It means that people's happiness changes despite any kind of set point that may set the range of their happiness, there is, there are changes that occur across time, some individual and some normative or average. The people who came from really difficult unhappy childhoods, whether they were the privileged people or the, you know, folks from the less privileged areas of Boston, were there any differences regarding, I mean, did they tend to grow up unhappy or were they able to overcome that adversity? Yeah. So again, another really critical question. And I think a lot of people are thinking about their childhood and what impact it may have on their adult life. And what we find is there are connections.
这意味着人们的幸福会改变，尽管任何可能设定他们幸福范围的设定点，确实存在，随着时间推移发生的变化，有些是个人化的，有些是规范性的或平均的。那些来自非常困难、不快乐童年的人，无论是特权阶层还是来自波士顿不太优越地区的人，在这些方面有什么不同吗？我的意思是，他们倾向于长大后不快乐，还是能够克服那种逆境？是的。所以又是另一个非常关键的问题。我认为很多人都在思考他们的童年以及它可能对他们的成年生活产生什么影响。我们发现确实有联系。
So extraordinary data allows us to ask these really interesting questions. So we see, for example, a link between the ratings that our researchers did when they went into the homes of the participants in the 1930s and rated the quality of the parenting, how warm, present, consistent the parenting was. And the quality of relationships when participants are in their 80s. So this is a 60-70-year time span. There is a connection. That connection is small.
所以非凡的数据使我们能够提出这些非常有趣的问题。例如，我们看到了研究人员在20世纪30年代进入参与者家中时所做的评分与育儿质量、育儿的温暖、存在、一致性之间的联系。以及参与者在80多岁时人际关系的质量。所以这是一个60-70年的时间跨度。确实有联系。这种联系很小。
So what that means for folks that are trying to make sense of research like this is that coming out of childhood with the benefit of a warm, loving set of conditions of childhood environment, huge benefit in terms of the way in which you might enter into adult relationships. But our relationships themselves affect how we develop across time. So there is a long, You can see it even into the 80s, but that reach is pretty small.
所以对于那些试图理解这类研究的人来说，这意味着带着温暖、充满爱的童年环境条件的好处走出童年，在进入成人关系的方式方面有巨大的好处。但我们的人际关系本身会影响我们随着时间的推移如何发展。所以确实有一个长期的，你甚至可以在80多岁时看到它，但那种影响相当小。
And that's because we learn things as we grow through adulthood, that we're in new relationships. We tend to grow and modify our expectations for relationships as we have good ones or as we have bad ones. So childhood relationships, I think, are important. It's a gift to go into adulthood with some of those positive experiences from childhood. And it's more challenging if you don't have them. But they're not determinative. It's not your fate is the key part. And I think that's really critical for people to recognize.
这是因为我们在成年过程中学到了东西，我们在新的人际关系中。当我们有好的关系或坏的关系时，我们倾向于成长并修改我们对人际关系的期望。所以我认为童年关系很重要。带着童年的一些积极经历进入成年是一种礼物。如果你没有它们，挑战会更大。但它们不是决定性的。关键部分是，这不是你的命运。我认为这对人们来说非常关键。
Now, science has evolved over the course of this study. And early on, you didn't have things like DNA or video or the kinds of things that are being collected now. What are these newer factors showing you that you weren't able to see maybe 60 years ago? Science has grown in so many ways along with the technologies. So the places we pay attention to have also changed. And it's partly driven by technology and our ability to look at new questions of things like genetic processes or, you know, internal bodily processes like our immune functioning or our inflammatory responses or things that would have been very difficult to assess when the study began. So it allows us different windows into trying to understand the mechanisms, for example, that might explain how relationships might get into our bodies and affect our health. So we've tried to harness those new technologies, all the ones that you're describing, brain.
现在，科学在整个研究过程中已经发展。早期，你们没有像DNA或视频或现在正在收集的那种东西。这些较新的因素向你们展示了什么，你们60年前可能无法看到？科学随着技术在许多方面都有所增长。所以我们关注的地方也发生了变化。它部分是由技术和我们观察新问题的能力驱动的，比如遗传过程，或者，你知道，内部身体过程，比如我们的免疫功能或我们的炎症反应，或者在研究开始时很难评估的事情。所以它为我们提供了不同的窗口，试图理解机制，例如，可能解释人际关系如何进入我们的身体并影响我们的健康。所以我们试图利用那些新技术，所有你描述的，大脑。
scans, blood assays to understand even epigenetic effects. So this is whether genes are turned on and off by life experiences. And we know from other research that relational experiences, particularly early on, have an impact on our epigenetics. So a concrete example is genes that affect our ability to fight invaders to the body, germs, are affected by loneliness and difficult childhood experiences. we've done some of the research that also points in that direction as well. We've been trying to study what happens for people who are aging and have the benefits of
扫描，血液分析，以了解甚至表观遗传效应。所以这是基因是否被生活经历开启和关闭。我们从其他研究中知道，关系经历，特别是在早期，对我们的表观遗传学有影响。所以一个具体的例子是，影响我们对抗身体入侵者、细菌能力的基因，受到孤独和困难童年经历的影响。我们也做了一些指向那个方向的研究。我们一直试图研究那些正在衰老并拥有以下好处的人会发生什么：
close connections to others. So they have partners that they're close with. And it's a secure mutually beneficial relationship. There's some physical benefits that we see from that as well, including signs for women, at least, that their cognitive functioning doesn't change as much. as other people's cognitive functioning does. And we're talking about in your 80s, so the general changes decline in cognitive functioning.
与他人的密切联系。所以他们有他们亲近的伴侣。这是一种安全的互利关系。我们也从中看到了身体上的好处，包括至少对女性来说，她们的认知功能不会改变那么多。像其他人的认知功能一样。我们谈论的是在80多岁时，所以一般的变化是认知功能下降。
But people in those secure connected relationships for women, they show less of a decline across a three-year period. So we're trying to make sense of the mechanisms that might connect relationships to our physical and even our brain health. And these new technologies are extraordinary for doing that. But it also means that we're looking in a different place. 30 years ago, maybe not that surprising that relationships were connected to emotional well-being,
但那些处于安全联系关系中的女性，她们在三年期间表现出的下降较少。所以我们试图理解可能将人际关系与我们的身体甚至大脑健康联系起来的机制。这些新技术对于做到这一点非常了不起。但这也意味着我们在不同的地方寻找。30年前，人际关系与情感健康有关可能并不那么令人惊讶，
but it was surprising that it would affect our physical health. And there's been just extraordinary research that's been done in the last 20 years, maybe a little bit longer that showed these incredible connections between our experiences and close connections and our physical health. I'd like to talk just about one, Kim, as an example, because I think it's really lovely research and it's really elegant science as well. This was work that Jim Cohn did at the University of Virginia, and he exposed people to a mild experience of pain. So he pricked them, their skin, for example.
但它会影响我们的身体健康是令人惊讶的。在过去的20年里，也许稍微长一点，已经进行了非常非凡的研究，显示了我们的经历和密切联系与我们的身体健康之间这些令人难以置信的联系。我想谈谈一个，金，作为一个例子，因为我认为这是非常可爱的研究，也是非常优雅的科学。这是吉姆·科恩在弗吉尼亚大学所做的工作，他让人们接触到轻微的疼痛体验。所以他刺了他们，他们的皮肤，例如。
And in one condition, people did this alone by themselves. They were in a brain scanner, and another condition, they were holding the hand of another. And in that second condition, sometimes the hand that you were holding was the hand of a loved one. And what Cohn found in this really interesting study, is that the areas of the brain that light up when we experience pain, that activity was diminished when people were allowed to hold the hand of another and particularly diminished when they were
在一种情况下，人们独自一人做这件事。他们在脑部扫描仪中，在另一种情况下，他们握着另一个人的手。在第二种情况下，有时你握着的手是爱人的手。科恩在这项非常有趣的研究中发现，当我们经历疼痛时，大脑中亮起的区域，当人们被允许握住另一个人的手时，这种活动会减少，特别是当他们
holding the hand of a loved one. And that's just one example of the way that relationships might be able to affect our physical health and in this case our brain activity in a pretty profound way. So I think we're beginning to understand that with the help of these new technologies. It's very exciting. I'm eager to see sort of where it takes us in the future. There must have been some influence by participating in the study, that there was a connection, say, between the researcher and the participant. Do you have any sense of how much that may have influenced the outcome? I mean, people from your book, some of the people who were interviewed actually looked forward to the regular interactions. You know, has that skewed things in a way that would make a difference, do you think?
握着爱人的手时。这只是人际关系可能能够以一种相当深刻的方式影响我们的身体健康，在这种情况下是我们的大脑活动的一个例子。所以我认为我们开始在这些新技术的帮助下理解这一点。这非常令人兴奋。我很渴望看到它在未来会把我们带向何方。参与这项研究一定有一些影响，即研究人员和参与者之间存在联系。您对这在多大程度上影响了结果有什么感觉吗？我的意思是，您书中的人，一些被采访的人实际上期待着定期的互动。你知道，这是否以一种会产生差异的方式扭曲了事情，您认为？
So this is a really interesting question. It's also a challenge you wanted to answer scientifically. If we really wanted to find the answer, we would somehow randomly assign people to not answer study questions for a period of time and follow them and also look at people who are answering them. So I can't give a really rigorous scientific answer. All I can give you are the anecdotal evidence that we have from participants. So we asked them what their experience was like participating.
这是一个非常有趣的问题。这也是一个你想从科学角度回答的挑战。如果我们真的想找到答案，我们会以某种方式随机分配一些人，让他们在一段时间内不回答研究问题，并跟踪他们，同时观察那些正在回答问题的人。所以我无法给出一个非常严谨的科学答案。我能给你的只是我们从参与者那里得到的轶事证据。所以我们询问了他们参与研究的体验是怎样的。
And most of them talked about it as a very positive experience. They talked about being able to kind of check in with themselves, thinking about where they were spending their time, how they were doing. I think, again, from many of these participants born in the early 19th century, this was an opportunity to talk about experiences that they were really socialized not to talk about. And in fact, they told us that they shared experiences with us that they never talked about with other people. So we think this sort of regular check-in might have some benefits for anyone, not just people in a study. And part of what we do in the good life is share some exercises and assessments like the assessments in the study that anyone can use to check
他们中的大多数人谈到这是一种非常积极的体验。他们谈到能够审视自己，思考他们把时间花在了哪里，他们过得怎么样。我认为，对于许多出生在19世纪初的参与者来说，这是一个谈论他们实际上被社会化教育而不敢谈论的经历的机会。事实上，他们告诉我们，他们与我们分享了从未与其他人谈论过的经历。所以我们认为这种定期的自我审视可能对任何人都有好处，不仅仅是研究中的人。我们在《美好生活》中所做的一部分工作就是分享一些练习和评估，就像研究中的那些评估一样，任何人都可以用来进行自我审视，
in, particularly around their social functioning. So in the book, we highlight this idea about social fitness being really important. And like physical fitness, we need to exercise those muscles. So we provide some exercises that people can do to check in once a year or more regularly if they feel like they can use that support. But this connection people had to the study, It was quite extraordinary, and you see it partly from their sense that it helped them. We also have, we have, you know, file drawers full of information about the participants,
特别是在他们的社会功能方面。所以在书中，我们强调了社会适应能力非常重要的观点。就像身体健康一样，我们需要锻炼这些肌肉。因此，我们提供了一些练习，人们可以每年进行一次自我审视，如果他们觉得需要这种支持，可以更频繁地进行。但是人们与这项研究的联系是非常非凡的，你可以从他们认为这对自己有帮助的感觉中部分地看到这一点。我们还有，你知道，装满参与者信息的档案柜，
all the questionnaires they were filled out. But we also have letters from the participants and letters from their families. And people were quite devoted to the study. It became an important part of their life. Some of these men and their families decided to donate their bodies and their brains to the study, which is an ultimate, you know, kind of example of sacrifice for others. And importantly, in addition to that incredible compliance for the first generation, when we went to the children of the original participants, almost two-thirds of them said, yes, I'd love to participate in that study that my parents have been participating. I've always been curious what kinds of questions you all ask.
所有他们填写的问卷。但我们也有来自参与者及其家人的信件。人们对这项研究非常投入。它成为了他们生活中重要的一部分。其中一些男性及其家人决定将他们的身体和大脑捐献给这项研究，这是一种为他人牺牲的终极例子。重要的是，除了第一代人令人难以置信的配合之外，当我们联系原始参与者的子女时，近三分之二的人说，是的，我很乐意参加我父母一直参与的那项研究。我一直很好奇你们问的是什么样的问题。
So, yes, I'm happy to participate. So when you talk to the children, they were then accepted into the study in the same way that the original participants were? So it wasn't they were just reflecting upon their fathers, but they became subjects as well. Exactly. Exactly. So both of those things were important. We did ask them about their memories of growing up and these families that we follow very closely because that allows us to look at the difference between our retrospection and our eyewitness reports.
所以，是的，我很乐意参加。那么当你和这些子女交谈时，他们是以和原始参与者同样的方式被纳入研究的吗？所以他们不仅仅是在回顾他们的父亲，他们也成为了研究对象？完全正确。完全正确。所以这两件事都很重要。我们确实询问了他们关于成长过程中的记忆，以及我们密切跟踪的这些家庭，因为这使我们能够观察我们的回顾与目击者报告之间的差异。
And that gap is really interesting. It might tell us something about the way anyone adapts over time and whether that was more, whether the gap might be bigger in certain kinds of families and what the consequences of that gap may be. So we did ask them to reflect on their childhood experiences. And that was the focus of one of our federally funded grants from the National Institute on Aging. But we were really interested in their own experience as well. So these are baby boomer age participants that range widely from, depending on the marriages of the original participants from somewhere in late 20s all the way up into the 70s. So one of the questions, for example, that we can ask with this sample is, where were
这种差距非常有趣。它可能告诉我们一些关于任何人随时间适应的方式，以及这种差距在某些类型的家庭中是否更大，以及这种差距可能带来的后果。所以我们确实要求他们反思自己的童年经历。这是我们从美国国家老龄化研究所获得的联邦资助拨款的重点之一。但我们也对他们自己的经历非常感兴趣。所以这些是婴儿潮一代的参与者，根据原始参与者的婚姻情况，年龄跨度很大，从20多岁一直到70多岁。所以，例如，我们可以用这个样本问的一个问题是，你在数字鸿沟方面处于什么位置，
you in terms of the digital divide, the introduction of technologies like cell phones and internet and social media, does that have an impact on the way that you conduct your social connections? This data collection happened before and after COVID. Some are also interested in the impact of the pandemic and, again, which side of the social divide you were on and how that might have helped you navigate or hindered your navigation during the pandemic. So last question, what's next for the study? Are you enrolling yet another generation of participants are collecting different data? There are other research questions that you want to pursue? There are. We're still, I feel like it's an important resource and we're trying to steward it properly.
手机、互联网和社交媒体等技术的引入，是否对你进行社交联系的方式产生了影响？这些数据收集发生在新冠疫情之前和之后。有些人也对疫情的影响感兴趣，同样，你处于社会鸿沟的哪一边，以及这可能如何帮助你应对或阻碍了你在疫情期间的应对。最后一个问题，这项研究的下一步是什么？你们是否正在招募新一代的参与者，或者在收集不同的数据？还有其他你们想要追求的研究问题吗？有的。我们仍然觉得这是一个重要的资源，我们正在努力妥善管理它。
So with the second generation of participants, we're asking lots of questions about social media and technology, impact on social connection. We, because we were somewhat lucky about the timing of our assessments, we're able to look a little bit at the impact of the pandemic. But we're in the middle of a large data collection now with that second generation. Part of what we're asking about as a sneak preview is we're asking about their sense of when they might become grandparents, because we think this sample might be an interesting sample to think about a prospective transition to grandparenthood study, which as far as we can tell has never been done. But if we plan it well, this would allow us or future researchers to look very carefully at another very important life cycle event that I think has been underappreciated in terms of what impact it might have on people's well-being. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Schultz.
所以对于第二代参与者，我们正在询问很多关于社交媒体和技术对社会联系影响的问题。因为我们在评估时间安排上比较幸运，我们能够稍微观察一下疫情的影响。但我们现在正在对第二代进行大规模的数据收集。作为预告，我们询问的一部分是关于他们对自己何时可能成为祖父母的看法，因为我们认为这个样本可能是一个有趣的样本，可以用来思考一项关于祖父母身份的前瞻性转变研究，据我们所知，这项研究从未做过。但如果我们计划得当，这将使我们或未来的研究人员能够非常仔细地观察另一个非常重要的生命周期事件，我认为在它可能对人们的幸福感产生什么影响方面，这一点一直被低估了。好吧，我想感谢你今天加入我，舒尔茨博士。
This has been really interesting. And I think this is a fascinating study that you're part of. Thank you. Thank you for having me, Kim. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at
这真的非常有趣。我认为这是一个你参与的迷人研究。谢谢。谢谢你邀请我，金。这是一种荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。请给我们留下评论。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以通过电子邮件发送给我们：
speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。